what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm your host
Warren Thompson and today we have a new
update about the case of Jonathan Majors
Jonathan Majors actually appeared in
court this morning this was his set
court date and things were supposed to
begin however it does appear like there
have been some delays and some new
allegations against him are now coming
out because apparently more alleged
victims are coming out as well so we'll
talk about what this means for the case
of Jonathan majors and of course what it
means for Marvel Cinematic Universe and
his role of King the Conqueror if you
have not seen recently the Loki season 2
trailer dropped and Jonathan Majors is
shown in it of course Jonathan Majors
plays King to conqueror in the MCU and
in the Loki season 2 trailer he plays a
variant of Kang called Victor timely
Marvel did show him up close and
personal also recently Marvel had
delayed the release of Ant-Man and the
Wasps quantumania assembled project They
delayed this indefinitely a ridge
originally because of everything that
was going on with Jonathan Majors
however they did release it this was a
great sign and it's a great sign that we
are seeing Jonathan majors in the
promotions for Loki season 2 as well and
we thought things were looking pretty
good for him however today a slight
curveball has been thrown at us however
it doesn't look that bad if anything as
you'll find out it seems like Jonathan
majors and his team were the ones that
were more prepared but of course we'll
tell you everything you need to know and
if you want to keep up to date with this
situation in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the recent
videos and we're also doing a giveaway
if you subscribe and leave a comment
you're automatically entered for a
chance to win an Xbox series X A PS5
some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items the winner gets to pick one item
and we pick a winner at the end of each
month so this article is coming to us
from variety.com with the title Jonathan
Majors assault trial delayed new date
set for September now he did appear in
court this morning in fact he recently a
few hours ago got out of court and
variety offers us a a brief little
description of what happened in court
let's just go through the Variety
article right now it starts off by
stating the domestic violence trial of
Jonathan majors has been delayed to
September the 33 year old actor returned
to court on Thursday today for what was
supposed to be the start of the trial
but the prosecution said it was not
ready because it's still obtaining
Discovery Majors wearing a gray suit
entered the courtroom holding hands with
girlfriend Megan good he carried a Bible
and notebook as he approached the bench
at 9 42 a.m this is Eastern time with
his criminal defense lawyer Priya
Chaudhry she alleged the delay is
because the prosecutors weren't timely
in turning over evidence a new trial
date has been set for September 6th now
let's talk about what exactly this means
it was not ready because the prosecution
was still obtaining Discovery and they
weren't timely in turning in evidence
what this most likely is is more
accusations and more people coming out
because this is what variety had
actually reported in the past before the
first original court date the
prosecution claimed that more alleged
victims came forward so this is most
likely connected somewhat to the
evidence that the prosecution has not
turned in yet but it also is probably
them trying to counter the evidence that
Jonathan majors and his team have
against them Jonathan Majors his lawyer
chaudry issued a statement after the
court appearance stating pretty much the
same thing claiming that Jonathan Majors
is and I quote the real victim in this
shameful ordeal end quote she also went
on to say quote he has had his life
career and reputation torn apart yet he
remains unwavering in his determination
to be absolved from this harrowing
ordeal end quote so the entire time
since the very first day that he was
arrested Jonathan majors and his law
team have stated he is innocent and not
only is he Innocent but he is actually
the victim in this situation let me
further explain this as the report
States Jonathan Majors was arrested in
Manhattan New York on March 25th and he
was charged with accounts of assault an
aggravated harassment following an
alleged domestic dispute with his then
girlfriend at the time Grace Jabari at
the time of the arrest a then unnamed
woman told officers that she was
assaulted and taken to the hospital with
minor injuries to her head and neck this
unnamed woman of course is Grace jibari
his ex-girlfriend majors has pleaded not
guilty to the four charges leveled
against him and there was a charge of
strangulation that ended up being
dropped right now as it stands if
convicted of misdemeanor charges of
harassment and assault Jonathan Majors
could face up to one year in jail so
that's what happened and those are the
charges held against him however since
then Jonathan majors's Law team has come
out and presented a lot of evidence in
his favor from what we understand
Jonathan majors and his girlfriend at
the time Grace Jabari were in a private
car with a private driver Grace Jabari
allegedly wanted to see Jonathan
majors's phone he said no they got into
a little dispute over it which resulted
in her hitting him a little bit and
according to the law team the driver can
attest to this and will testify in court
that this is actually what happened they
also state that the driver is going to
testify that Jonathan Majors is the one
that told him to pull over the car in
which Jonathan Majors then got out of
the car but Grace Shibari tried to pull
him back in eventually Jonathan Majors
did get out of the car Grace Jabari
stayed and she left and went to a
nightclub what's interesting is at this
point in time this domestic dispute in
the car is where Grace Jabari was
allegedly assaulted hurting her hand her
neck her head and her ear however she
went to a club after and there is photo
and video evidence of her behaving just
fine not injured at all using the hand
that she's said was hurt touching the
ear that she said was hurt she was
drinking a lot she was dancing she was
talking to the DJ basically no signs of
her being hurt at all and this is
evidence that Jonathan majors's team has
presented to the courtroom they also
have CCTV footage of the street of where
Jonathan Majors actually got out of the
car that allegedly shows her trying to
pull him back in in which he finally
escapes and walks away from the
situation then based off of what we know
Jonathan Majors returned to his
Penthouse apartment the next morning
around 10 or 11 A.M in which she was
already in there however she was in his
room and he could not get the door open
apparently the closet was locked so he
called the maintenance man in which he
came over and opened the door in which
they found Grace Jabari passed out drunk
on the floor passed out drunk half naked
then what happened here is Jonathan
Majors called the cops himself because
he had no idea what happened then
according to majors's law team statement
when the cops got there they seemingly
kind of coached Grace Jabari into
stating that it was Jonathan Majors that
assaulted her that is when they arrested
Jonathan Majors Jonathan Majors lawyer
Priya Chaudhary states that there is a
lot of racial bias in the role of this
investigation and she is calling this a
Witch Hunt against Jonathan Majors but
also the maintenance man is prepared to
testify in court as well on what he saw
opening the door and finding the woman
passed out drunk cap naked on the floor
so this is all the evidence that majors
and his team has prepared we haven't
really heard of any evidence that the
prosecution has so far and apparently
their evidence wasn't even ready for
court which is why the court date has
been postponed at this point in time
it's been postponed essentially a month
now to September 6th now as far as what
this means for Marvel right now it means
they have to wait just a little bit
longer to find out what the actual
verdict is going to be if Jonathan
Majors is convicted and he goes to jail
they're gonna drop him as king the
Conqueror however if he has proven
innocent they're going to keep him as
king the Conqueror in the MCU so this
month the life of the try I might put a
little bit of a delay in their plans
because they obviously want to know
what's going to happen sooner than later
however with all the strikes going on
right now everything's pretty much
getting delayed anyways so it's not
super terrible news but of course if you
want to keep up to date with the
situation be sure to subscribe and hit
that notification Bell if we hear
anything else we'll be sure to let you
know in the meantime let us know what
you think about this situation in the
comments down below don't forget to
follow us on Instagram and Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching wolf
foreign